Okay, so adding Memcache to Ascii Chan gave us two
new properties that are really nice. One is that our cache
survives restarts. Before when we're using that dictionary cache, if we
updated our code, either locally or in production, our cache gets
cleared. That's not a good quality. Or if, you know, in
production if Google for some reason. Moves us a different machine
or something like that. What's going to happen, our cache would get
cleared. Which is also you know, it's not a good property,
especially if you have a lot of traffic. And
our app is now stateless, which is the key
to scaling. What stateless means is our app between
any two requests, stores no state. And that means we
ca, that, that a, a number of, a number
of properties come from this. You know, there's no state
between requests. Which means our apps are now interchangeable.
Which means we can have multiple apps without any drama.
You know, we have our load balancer, we have our Memcached.
And in between those two pieces of technology are as many
app servers as we need. You know, adding more app servers
is easy. likewise, removing an app server is also easy and,
and not painful. And it means our apps can be scaled
independently of. Our cache and our database. So we've got our
app servers. You know, we've got our, our database, and you
know we've got our cache. And if we find ourselves needing more
app servers, we can add one. Let's add our load balancer in here
for good measure. So now I've got all these pieces. We need another
app server we add one. If we need another Memcache, we add one.
Having lots of caches means we won't have to scale our database quite
so fast, but if we need more database, we talked about this in
unit three. You know, we can go with replication or we can go
with sharding. But now you're starting to see the the kind of the
bigger picture of how a website might grow. If you're really data heavy.
You have lots of databases and maybe lots of caches. You know, if
your database is, is very read heavy but not [UNKNOWN] it's not actually
not a lot of data you would have more caches. If your, if
your application is very computationally intensive, maybe
you have lots of app servers and
you don't need so much database support or not so much cache support.
But what we want to do, is we want to make sure that all of
these different pieces can grow independently.
And that's kind of what scaling is
all about, is putting yourself in a position so that when your app is
constrained in different ways, you can grow each part kind of independent of the
others. And now that our app is stateless, it's really easy to do that. And
Memcache helps a lot because all of the, all of the state is either stored in
cookies, the DB or Memcache, but not the apps. And that's really handy.